and I'm a place where the university will
do everything to create an
ideal environment for you to do your research
so I'm not just talking about the
laboratory,
I'm just talking about libraries I'm not just talking about a
balance of seminars as well the entire
cultural environment
the theaters  musical events everything
that is linked to the university has the tone of the
university creating this
perfect environment for you to carry out your
work
the department where you joined they have
this series of seminars every week
in this seminar they receive
researchers from both the united states
and other countries
we present to your results your
work and to have contact with these
presentations and only of high quality
I think that was the great differential that
I witnessed here during my during
the same period of research
mainly because I was able to have
contact with these with this with these
presentations  high quality is
contact with the researchers this
will definitely help the  increase my
network of collaborations in the future for
potential potential studies when I
return to Brazil I voted to
apply this new knowledge and
new tools that I have
acquired here both to develop
research there and to help in the
training of resident physicians in the
same hospital